Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 26, wie beim letzten Mal, wieder vom Linux-Tag 2006 in Wiesbaden und wieder habe ich mir einen interessanten Gesprächspartner von den Fluren herausgebohrt. In diesem Fall ist es Georg Greve von der Free Software Foundation in Europe. Du kannst mich hören, wunderbar, super. Ja, ich habe es schon gesagt, FSF Europe, Free Software Foundation ist sicherlich dem einen oder anderen ein Begriff, insbesondere hier bei unserer Zielgruppe, aber vielleicht kannst du ja nochmal kurz den historischen Abriss wiedergeben, was die Free Software Foundation eigentlich genau ist, wie sie entstanden ist und wo sie heute steht. Dazu werden wir dann sicherlich danach noch kommen.
Genau, also die Free Software Foundation geht zurück auf die Anfänge des GNU-Projekts Anfang der 80er Jahre am MIT in Boston, wurde gegründet von Richard Storman, der ja 1983 ausgerufen hat, man müsse jetzt die Welt befreien und freie Software nach vorne bringen, um das GNU-Projekt juristisch zunächst hauptsächlich zu betreuen. Sie hat dann sehr früh angefangen, 1985 gegründet, die Rechte der GNU-Autoren zu bündeln und zu sichern und auch zu schützen über die GNU General Public License, die ja das Prinzip des Copy Left erfunden hat und als die meist verwandte freie Software-Lizenz heute eine wahnsinnig weite Verbreitung hat. Mehr als 50, 60 Prozent der freien Software stehen unter der GPL.
Ja, da würde ich ganz genau mal ein bisschen einhaken, weil das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so die Geburtsstunde, so ein bisschen so auch dieser paradiesische Sündenfeil, in dem Richard Stormen da so teilgenommen hat. Wenn ich das richtig erinnere, war er ja damals bei diesem AI Lab auch so eine der Kernzellen der Ur-Hacker-Bewegung, wo damals ja noch ein relativ, wie soll ich sagen, offener Umgang gepflegt wurde im Austausch von Code. Also da gab es dieses Timesharing-System und alle konnten alles sehen und es gab da irgendwie keine Zugriffsrechte und der Source Code ging hin und her. Und als dann nach und nach einer nach dem anderen so zu den Firmen ging, hat ja dann sozusagen Richard Stormen da seine göttliche Erweckung erfahren. Keine Ahnung, wann die in der Blitz genau getroffen hat. Aber das war ja im Prinzip die Motivation, überhaupt dieses GNU-Projekt zu gründen.
Ja, wobei das Interessante ist halt, es hat mit der Kommerzialität tatsächlich wenig zu tun. Ihm ging es darum, dass in dem Moment, als ihm verboten werden sollte, in irgendeiner Art und Weise anderen Menschen zu helfen, denen er gern helfen möchte, als ihm verboten wurde, sein Wissen einzusetzen, um anderen so zu helfen, wie er das könnte und wollte, zu dem Zeitpunkt, als man ihm sagte, unterzeichne dieses NDA, dieses Non-Disclosure Agreement, sodass du dein Wissen, das du jetzt kriegst, nicht mit anderen teilst. Das war der Moment, wo er gesagt hat, das kann ich für mich moralisch nicht vertreten. Das war so ein bisschen die moralische Sternstunde für ihn, wo er gesagt hat, ich muss es möglich machen, dass Menschen ihr Wissen miteinander teilen können. Es ist nicht richtig, dass dieses Wissen immer nur Einzelnen gehört. Ich will mein Wissen teilen dürfen, das soll mir niemand verbieten können. Und da fing das an.
Genau, und angefangen hat er ja damit erst mal, also er hat ja eigentlich gleich von Anfang an hier das Ziel gehabt. So GNU steht ja für GNU, das ist Not Unix, das heißt, die ursprüngliche Vision war von Anfang an, ich programmiere dieses bei uns derzeit so populäre, aber halt nach wie vor in den Händen von AT&T gehaltene und von daher geschlossene System Unix. Das möchte ich ganz gerne mal komplett neu machen, aber es ist halt nicht Unix, auch wenn es dann ist wie Unix. Und angefangen hat er dann eben mit dem C-Compiler, den erst mal zu machen, was ja im Prinzip die Grundlage jeglicher Open-Source-Development ist, wie man es heute kennt. Und wann hieß das dann Free Software Foundation? Also wann kam dann dieser eigentliche Organisationsaspekt mit rein?
Gegründet hat er die 1985. Das GNU-Projekt wurde ausgerufen, 83, 84 fing er an mit der Arbeit. Er kündigte auch seinen Job beim MIT. Jetzt haben wir hier Besucher anstürme per Telefon.
Das können wir einfach mal ignorieren.
Hervorragend. Ja, er kündigte daraufhin dann seinen Job beim MIT, um eben auch sicherzustellen, dass das Urheberrecht für die Arbeit am GNU-Projekt eindeutig bei ihm liegt, dass das MIT nicht irgendwann nachträglich kommen könne und sagt, ja gut, du warst bei uns angestellt, insofern haben wir ein Recht an deiner Arbeit und jetzt wollen wir das unter bestimmten Lizenzen rausbringen. Das wollte er von vornherein vermeiden. Und aus diesem Grund hat er damals tatsächlich dann den Schritt gemacht, hat beim MIT aufgehört, hat da zwar dann noch gewohnt, die haben ihm auch ein Büro gestellt, in dem er dann auch geschlafen hat. Da gibt es viele legendäre Stories. Aber tatsächlich hat er zu dem Zeitpunkt die Tauhe gekappt und gesagt, ich muss der Herr über mein Urheberrecht sein. Das muss mir gehören, damit ich es dann weitergeben kann.
Wobei ja Urheberrecht jetzt in den USA anders gehandhabt wird als in Europa, also so wie man das hier kennt, auch wenn viele Leute eher davon ausgehen, dass wir dasselbe Copyright hätten und dass es auch Copyright heißen würde, was ja nicht der Fall ist. Und hier gibt es eben Urheberrecht, da drüben basiert eben alles auf dem Kopieren. Und bei uns eher auf der eigentlichen ursprünglichen schöpferischen Tat. Jetzt bist du ja Vertreter der Free Software Foundation Europe. Hast du da eigentlich auch einen tollen Namen? Du bist Präsident, oder? Jetzt setzt man einen richtigen Präsidenten zusammen. Okay, wann wurde das Projekt FSF Europe gegründet? Seit wann gibt es das?
Es gibt die Free Software Foundation Europe seit Anfang 2001. Wir haben gegen Ende 2000 eine sogenannte Declaration of Intent, also eine Absichtserklärung veröffentlicht. Seitdem gibt es die Free Software Foundation Europe auch im öffentlichen Raum, sozusagen, oder bekannt öffentlich. Das geht zurück auf eine Diskussion, die ich mit Richard hatte, irgendwann im Jahr 1998, 1999, wo für mich sehr klar war, dass die Free Software Foundation als Organisation, wenn sie ihre Ziele weiter erreichen will, sich auch umstrukturieren muss. Sie muss sich weiterentwickeln als Organisation, denn auch die ursprüngliche FSF in Boston, die Richard gegründet hat, hat relativ schnell angefangen, sich eben nicht nur um die juristischen Belange des GNU-Projekts zu kümmern, sondern zunehmend freie Software politisch, juristisch mit einer sehr langfristigen Perspektive zu vertreten. Das ist auch das Besondere an der FSF immer gewesen. Die FSF war die Organisation, die nicht nur als Erste in diesem Feld aktiv war politisch, sondern sie war auch diejenige, die da zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gesagt hat, wir müssen das sehr langfristig betreiben, und die sich deswegen manchmal auch durchaus unbeliebt gemacht hat, auch in der Community, weil einige der Aussagen dann doch sehr unbequem waren. Aber wenn es als notwendig und richtig erkannt wurde für den langfristigen Erfolg, Free Software, dann wurde das trotzdem vertreten.
Was würdest du da jetzt so nennen als unpopuläre Maßnahmen, die da so jetzt im Zustand...
Es fing beispielsweise an mit der Bündelung der Rechte, also Urheberrechtsübertragung, GPL, die ganze Aufwand, der da auch dranhängt. Da haben einige Leute durchaus sehr laut auch gesagt, dass er alles verschwendete Liebesmühe und alles völlig irrelevant und unwichtig. Und das müsse man nicht machen. Der Bekannteste, der das gesagt hat, war Eric Raymond. Sein Buch The Cathedral and the Bazaar ist letztlich tatsächlich eine Kampfschrift gegen die FSF gewesen. Das sieht man auch noch, wenn man eine 08er-Version oder sowas auf dem Internet sucht, das für irgendeinen Linux-Kongress hat er die mal gemacht. Da meinte er, das sei alles völliger Unsinn, das bräuchte man nicht. Die FSF hat das aber gemacht, weil sie wusste irgendwann, dann käme es go. Wir wussten nicht, dass es go sein würde, aber wir wussten, jemand würde kommen. Und der go-Fall hat sehr deutlich gezeigt, wie wichtig es ist, sich um diese Frage zu kümmern.
Also go, SCO, Santa Cruz Operation, eigentlich ein ganz gut in der Geschichte von Unix verwurzeltes Unternehmen. Mich hat das ein bisschen gewundert, dass ausgerechnet die da so aus dem Hinterhalt kamen. Aber das lag wahrscheinlich daran, dass sie für ihr eigentliches Business-Modell so recht keine Zukunft mehr gesehen haben. Ich kenne SCO Unix halt noch im Prinzip mit als Pionier. Die waren ja im Prinzip die Gruppe, die seinerzeit Xenix und damit eben das erste Unix überhaupt so auf billige PC-Plattformen gebracht hat. Damals noch so 80286, wo eigentlich ja die technischen Voraussetzungen so für die Anforderungen von Unix noch nicht so gegeben waren. Sie sind ja dann immer auch gemeinsam Weg mit Microsoft gegangen eine ganze Weile, bis sie sich dann eigenständig präsentiert haben. Aber ja, SCO Unix wollte dann halt irgendwann keiner mehr. Genau, und worauf du halt anspielst, ist dann eben, dass sie zu IBM gegangen sind und gesagt haben, was war eigentlich genau die Argumentationslinie bei SCO?
Ja, SCO hat letztlich entdeckt, nachdem sie größeren Venture-Kapitaleinfluss kriegten von einem durch Microsoft unterstützten Venture-Kapitalisten, dass sie jetzt glauben, Linux, spezifisch auch der kernel, von dem ich jetzt rede, sei mit ihren Urheberrechten irgendwie in Konflikt und dann haben sie halt versucht, die großen Vertriebshäuser anzugehen und auch einige große Kunden, also an Daimler-Benz zum Beispiel haben sie auch versucht, sich ran zu wagen, sie haben sich mit DreadHat angelegt und anderen, wobei das, also sich mit IBM anzulegen, war wahrscheinlich der dümmste Schachzug, den sie überhaupt noch hätten machen können.
Das denke ich allerdings auch, beziehungsweise generell sich mit Open Source anzulegen, weil ich kann mich noch ganz gut dran erinnern, als so die Nachricht ausbrach, war ja eigentlich unisono so die Reaktion, so aha, da will sich aber einer eine richtig blutige Nase holen. Ich glaube, das haben die gar nicht so gesehen, dass sie da gegen die Wand rennen.
Das Problem ist, mit einer kleineren Firma mit weniger tiefen Taschen, hätten sie es vielleicht sogar noch länger durchhalten können. Aber IBM ist nicht dafür bekannt gefangen, dazu machen, wenn man die einmal juristisch genug agert.
Ihr habt uns als Beige pinkelt.
Das war völlig klar, dass von SCO nichts überbleiben würde als rauchende Ruinen, als sie IBM angeklagt haben.
Ich bin kurz abgeschweift, eigentlich waren wir ja bei diesem Verhältnis zwischen Richard Stormen und Eric Raymond, der ja diesen Begriff Open Source eigentlich ja auch bekannt gemacht hat, nicht zuletzt durch dieses Buch, was du beschrieben hast, oder diesen Text, den er ursprünglich mal zu rausgebracht hat, Cathedral in the Bazaar.
Wobei witzigerweise haben die die ersten Versionen dieses Textes sprechen von Free Software.
Ah ja, also diese 08-Version, die du vorhin angesprochen hast. Und was hat ihn dann sozusagen da umschwenken lassen? Es gibt ja dann auch, ist nicht dieses OSDL, also Open Source, ne Entschuldigung, jetzt bringe ich zwei Sachen durcheinander. Die Open Source Licenses.
Es gibt eine Organisation namens Open Source Initiative, die wurde von einer Handvoll von Leuten gegründet. Das Ganze geht zurück auf das Jahr 1998. Da wurde im Silicon Valley, wir müssen uns noch ein bisschen zurückversetzen, 1998. Das war so richtig Dotcom-Boom, die Blase blies sich auf und mehr und mehr. Und alle Leute hatten ganz wahnsinnig viel Geld für ganz unsinnige Dinge. Und je schneller man das Geld los wurde, desto besser war man bewertet. Und da von diesem Geld wollten auch die Leute für freie Software was haben und dachten sich okay, aber dieses ganze Ding mit freier Software und freiem Markt und so, das verkauft sich bei den Venture-Kapitalisten nicht so gut. Wir brauchen irgendwie was, was fluffy klingt, was wir denen verkaufen können. Und haben deswegen in der Telefonkonferenz meines Wissens irgendwie gebrainstormt, wie das Ganze heißen solle. Und die beste Idee, die sie hatten, war Open Source. Und daraufhin hat Bruce Perrins zentral diese Initiative mitgegründet. Und sie haben Eric Raymond so ein bisschen zum Frontman gemacht, der der Open Source Initiative, mit dem Ziel eine Marketing-Kampagne für freie Software zu starten. Das hat sicherlich den Begriff Open Source bekannter gemacht, hat aber im Sinne einer Marketing-Kampagne für freie Software nicht so gut funktioniert, weil viele Leute nur den Begriff Open Source kennen und nicht, was dahinter steht. Der Begriff suggeriert sehr stark, es ginge um sichtbaren Source-Code. Wenn man den Source-Code irgendwie sehen könne, wäre es schon irgendwie auch Open Source. Und das ist nach der Open Source Definition, der Open Source Initiative völlig falsch. Denn die Definition ist abgeleitet von den Debian Free Software Guidelines, um genau zu sein, sie sind identisch. Die OZ hat nur freie Software gegen Open Source ausgetauscht und die Debian Free Software Guidelines wiederum beruhen auf der freien Software Definition der Free Software Foundation. Denn die Free Software Foundation hat das Debian-Projekt ursprünglich mit angeschoben, auch finanziell, um eine Community-basierte Distribution an den Start zu bringen. Weil zu dem Zeitpunkt gerade das GNU-Projekt war so weit, dass wir ein Betriebssystem hatten, der Linux-Körner funktionierte. Aber wir brauchten dann eine Möglichkeit, das auch weiter zu pflegen im Makro-Raum einer Distribution. Und Debian war da das beste Projekt, das sich anschickte, das zu tun. Deswegen hat die FSF das dann damals mit angeschoben.
Und wie ist dann jetzt das Verhältnis von der FSF zu der Open Source Initiative? Ist das irgendwie entspannt oder ist das irgendwie dasselbe in grün? Wo ist der Unterschied?
Na ja, die Open Source Initiative ist eine Gruppe, die durchaus eng auch mit der proprietären Softwarewelt verbundelt ist. Also das meiste, was man hört, sind eher so Treffen mit Microsoft und ähnliche Geschichten. Die geben eine Liste raus von Lizenzen, die sie als konform mit der Open Source Definition betrachten. Und das ist aber auch so ziemlich die einzige Aktivität, die sie in den letzten sieben Jahren entfaltet haben. Länger gibt es sie ja noch nicht.
Da ist ja ein ziemlicher Wildwuchs entstanden an Lizenzen, die da angeblich darunter fallen. Das letzte Mal, als ich geschaut habe, waren das, glaube ich, zehn verschiedene Lizenzen. Ich war von Apple hier und von Sun und so weiter. Jeder Firma hat ja dann heutzutage seine eigene Lizenz. Das macht die Sache ja nicht gerade besonders übersichtlich.
Ja, das ist schön, aber lässt sich halt nicht vermeiden. Es gibt mittlerweile irgendwie über 100 Lizenzen. Und letztlich muss man auch ganz klar sagen, dass zum allergrößten Teil, zu 99,5 Prozent oder so, sind die Lizenzen, die als Open Source-Lizenzen anerkannt werden, vom OSI auch, Free Software-Lizenzen für die FSF. Weil letztlich die Definitionen beruhen aufeinander. Die Open Source-Definition geht ja zurück auf die FSF-Free Software-Definition von der Historie her. Deswegen ist völlig klar, dass die Lizenzen, die sie damit charakterisieren, letztlich sehr stark identisch sind. Die sind zum allergrößten Teil.
Aber die BSD-Lizenzen gehören ja auch dazu. Natürlich. Nun ist der Ansatz der BSD-Lizenzen, also die Lizenzen, die vor allem dem BSD-Betriebssystem zugrunde liegen, aber es gibt auch zahlreiche Open Source-Projekte oder Free Software-Projekte, je nachdem. Das wäre mal ganz interessant, wie du das liest. Die halten auch unter der BSD-Lizenze. Im Gegensatz zur GPL, die ja mal sagt, wenn du es nimmst und wenn du es weiterverbreitest, dann musst du den Source samt seiner Änderungen wieder veröffentlichen. Die BSD-Lizenze ja insofern, wie die Anhänger sagen, noch freier, weil sie dir eben auch die Freiheit gibt, das nicht zu veröffentlichen. Wobei dann die Gegenargumentation immer ist, frei ist eben das, was für alle frei ist und nicht nur für den Einzelnen frei ist. Wird das richtig zusammengefasst? Oder ist euer Standpunkt dazu?
Da würde ich ein oder zwei Punkte klarstellen wollen. Das Erste ist, die BSD-Lizenzen sind freie Software-Lizenzen. Auch nach Definition der FSF, ohne Frage. Das ist das Erste, das ist sehr wichtig. Es gibt sogar Spezialfälle, wo wir empfohlen haben, die BSD-Lizenzen einzusetzen. OKVORBIS beispielsweise. Einfach um MP3 auszuhebeln, was ja patentbelastet ist, haben wir gesagt, ganz klar, die maximale Verbreitung auch in proprietärer Software dieses Formats ist wichtig und richtig und das erreichen wir besser, wenn wir eine Nicht-Copy-Left-Lizenz nehmen. Denn das ist der große Unterschied. Die GPL ist eine Copy-Left-Lizenz. Sie schützt also die Freiheit. Die BSD-Lizenzen schützen die Freiheit nicht. Wobei der Unterschied tatsächlich nicht ist, dass man es veröffentlichen müsste. Es gibt keine Veröffentlichungspflicht in der GPL. Ich kann GPL nehmen, ich kann die Änderung machen, ich kann sie behalten. Das Einzige, was ich nicht machen kann, ist, wenn ich diese Änderungen weitergebe an irgendjemand anders, oder wenn ich die Software selber weitergebe an irgendjemand anders, kann ich dieser Person die Freiheit nicht vorenthalten. Das ist die Copy-Left-Klausel. Die GPL sagt, wann immer eine Software mit GPL kommt, ist die Freiheit untrennbar mit ihr verbunden. Und kann auch von niemandem wieder entfernt werden. Das ist die große Idee dahinter. Und das hat sie auch so stark gemacht letzten Endes. BSD erlaubt alles inklusive eben auch, die Freiheit wieder anderen vorzuenthalten, auf der Arbeit anderer aufzubauen. Deswegen, Microsoft Windows enthält z.B. tonnenweise BSD-Code. Das ist völlig legal. Die BSD-Community akzeptiert das. Das ist auch gewollt von der Lizenz her. Das ist ein philosophischer Unterschied zwischen absoluter Freiheit und zu versuchen, einen Kompromiss zu finden für die maximal mögliche Freiheit, für die maximale Anzahl an Personen. Richard Storm hat das mal ausgedrückt als deine Freiheit, deine Faust zu schwingen, endet an meiner Nase. Das ist ein bisschen so der Ansatz dahinter, dass die GPL sagt, wir wollen die maximal mögliche Freiheit in einer Gesellschaft, wo Einzelne unter Umständen auch bereit sind, sich auf Kosten der Gesellschaft zu bereichern und auch gegen die Interessen der gesamten Gesellschaft. Und wir suchen eine Lizenz zu schaffen, die in einer unperfekten Welt funktioniert. Hätten wir eine perfekte Welt, wären die beiden Lizenzen eh identisch?
Oder wir bräuchten sie gar nicht, weil ja sowieso überall die Suppe irgendwie durch die Luft liegt. Aber da wissen wir ja leider noch nicht. Genau, das ist ein interessanter Punkt. Auch dieser Copy-Left-Gedanke, man kann es dem Namen ja schon entnehmen, versucht halt, Copyright anders zu benutzen. Also sozusagen auch unter Ausnutzung der Copyright-Gesetzgebung die Freiheit da zu beschützen. Jetzt gibt es ja auch noch ein paar andere Ansätze, insbesondere da, wo es eben von Software auch weggeht. Ich denke da zum Beispiel an das Wikipedia-Projekt, die ja so eine Variante der GPL, ich nenne es mal so, genommen haben, die GFDL, ich glaube auch in der Debian-Szene, in dieser Dokumentationszene um das Debian-Projekt herum entstandene Lizenz, die ja ähnlich wie die GPL für Software, Dokumentationen eben freistellt, und zwar eben auch so frei im Sinne von darf beliebig kommerziell verwendet werden. Der gesamte Wikipedia-Content steht da drunter. Und es bricht ja dann an manchen Stellen, wo man zum Beispiel, ja ich will im Mexikon das Logo einer Firma haben, aber das Firmenlogo ist jetzt irgendwie ja copyrighted. Und von daher kann ich es ja eigentlich gar nicht einstellen, weil es ja copyrighted und von daher halte ich ja das Recht nicht. Jetzt gibt es in den USA, glaube ich, Ausnahmeklauseln im Bereich Fair Use. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das in Deutschland aussieht. Aber wie ist denn das Verhältnis zur GFDL einerseits? Ist das überhaupt noch eine aktuelle Lizenz, die sozusagen die volle Unterstützung der FSF erfährt? Wird daran weitergearbeitet? Und wie ist das Verhältnis zu Creative Commons? Was versucht dann, ein etwas kompatibles Modell zu schaffen im Verhältnis zu Rechten, die man an seinen Urheberwerken hat?
Also letztlich gehen sowohl GFDL wie auch Creative Commons in gewisser Hinsicht auf ähnliche Gedanken zurück, nämlich die Notwendigkeit, eine urheberrechtliche Lizenz zu schaffen, die eben auch für Dinge funktioniert, die nicht Software sind. Denn eine der grundlegenden Erkenntnisse, die die FSF über die Jahre gemacht hat, ist, dass letztlich macht es keinen Sinn, alle Dinge gleich behandeln zu wollen. Viele der Probleme, die wir im Urheberrecht haben oder im Copyright im angloamerikanischen Raum, stammen daher, dass die Menschen versucht haben, eine Regel für alles zu finden. Und das macht überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Warum soll das neueste Album von Madonna dieselbe Behandlung erfahren, wie eine Gebrauchsanleitung für eine Waschmaschine, wie die Software in meinem Computer? Das sind völlig unterschiedliche Sachen. Die haben ganz andere Auswirkungen auf die Gesellschaft. Die haben ganz, ganz andere Geschäftsmodelle dahinter. Das macht gar keinen Sinn, dass die alle dieselben Regeln haben sollen. Aus dem Grunde haben wir gesagt, wir wiederholen nicht denselben Fehler in die andere Richtung und sagen, das muss jetzt alles genau so sein. Die vier Basisfreiheiten, die die FSF definiert hat, die gelten für Software, aber nicht für etwas anderes als Software.
Die vier Basisfreiheiten, kannst du die benennen?
Ja klar. Eigentlich müssten wir das noch mal irgendwie aufführen lassen. Jetzt müsste jeder irgendwie mal bei sich haben. Die vier Freiheiten, die FSF definieren, ist zum ersten die Freiheit der unbegrenzten Benutzung zu jedem Zweck. Also niemand darf mir sagen, wofür ich es einsetzen kann. Die nächste Freiheit ist die von Studium und Modifikation. Das heißt, ich kann lernen, wie es funktioniert, ich kann es anpassen, ich kann diese Software so umschreiben letztlich oder weiterentwickeln, wie ich es für sinnvoll halte. Die nächste Freiheit ist die Freiheit der Weitergabe. Das heißt, ich kann sie an andere kopieren, ich kann sie an andere weitergeben und damit die Software auch ihnen verfügbar machen. Und ich hab die vierte Freiheit, das ist die Freiheit der Weitergabe von Modifikationen, was bedeutet, dass ich meine Änderungen an andere weitergeben darf. Damit wird die zweite Freiheit, also die Studium- und Modifikationsfreiheit, auch für andere Menschen verfügbar über mittels Leute, auch wenn sie selber gar nicht programmieren können. Und wenn diese vier Basisfreiheiten gegeben sind, dann ist es Free Software.
Okay, also du siehst bei Creative Commons den gleichen Ansatz?
Bedingt, bedingt. Weil Creative Commons tatsächlich keinen minimalen Freiheitsstandard definiert.
Mittlerweile, also ursprünglich war es ja, glaube ich, auch mal das private Weiterkopieren, das ist auch so ein bisschen eingeschränkt worden, durch so Sampling-Lizenzen und sowas. Das ist ein schwieriges Feld.
Also Creative Commons per se sagt erstmal sehr wenig darüber aus, was für einen Lizenzstatus etwas hat. Weil es kann von sehr frei zu sehr proprietär gehen. Was Creative Commons etabliert, und das ist eine sehr gute Sache, ist eine Art Experimentierkasten. Ein Spielfeld, mit dem normale Menschen, die sich mit Urheberrecht überhaupt nicht auskennen und eigentlich auch nie auskennen wollten, mit dem sie mit Freiheiten experimentieren können. Denn das große Problem, das wir haben im Moment, ist, dass wir nicht wissen, was sind die notwendigen Freiheiten, für welches Feld genau. Wo müssen wir die Grenze ziehen? Was ist gesellschaftlich akzeptabel? Was geht zu weit? Wo wollen wir diese Grenze definieren? Und das wissen wir nicht für alle anderen Dinge. Für Software wissen wir es. Aber für andere Dinge wissen wir es nicht so genau. Und Creative Commons erlaubt uns letzten Endes, darüber zu diskutieren, damit zu experimentieren und das auf sehr einfache Art und Weise, ohne dabei Anwalt sein zu müssen. Und das ist eine sehr gute Sache. Das ist ein sehr, sehr hoher Verdienst von dem Lawrence Lessig, dass er es möglich gemacht hat, für normale Menschen dieses Experiment durchzuführen, mit ihren eigenen Musikstücken, mit ihren Podcasts und was auch immer, dass man versuchen kann, was funktioniert denn für mich, welche Basisfreiheiten sind denn wesentlich, welche sind nicht so wichtig, was funktioniert in welchem Gebiet besser, was funktioniert in welchem Gebiet schlechter. Und das möglich zu machen und diesen Dialog angeschoben zu haben, denn der Begriff Creative Commons ist ja nun in vieler Munde und wird auch auf vielen Konferenzen diskutiert. Die Verwertungsgesellschaften haben mittlerweile alle davon gehört und sind entweder irgendwie entsetzt bis skeptisch.
Zu Wissens zumindest.
Sie wissen, dass es existiert und es gibt eine Diskussion darüber und die Diskussion denke ich ist gesellschaftlich notwendig, um als Gesellschaft auch sehen zu können, welche Freiheiten brauchen wir denn zum Beispiel für Unterhaltungsmusik, für wissenschaftliche Bücher.
Im Anschieben des Dialogs scheint Lawrence Lessig in der Tat eine große Gabe zu haben. Jetzt hat er ja gerade eine andere, finstere Diskussion vom Zaun gebrochen und sozusagen das Unwort in den Mund genommen und beginnt eben jetzt darüber zu spekulieren, ob er nicht vielleicht auch die freie Gesellschaft mit Digital Rights oder Restrictions-Management-Systemen, also Software-Techniken, um einen Kopierschutz zu implementieren oder zumindest in irgendeiner Form die Verbreitung von Materialien besser zu kontrollieren oder man könnte es auch sagen, in irgendeiner Form einen Weg zu finden, wie man eben die Urheberrechte oder welche Rechte in dem Moment im jeweiligen Land auch gerade greifen für kreatives Material, auch nach der Auslieferung an einen Konsumenten irgendwie durchzusetzen. Ich habe die Diskussion jetzt im Detail noch nicht so verfolgt, aber wenn ich es richtig mitbekommen habe, hat er grundsätzlich erstmal die These aufgestellt, auch Open Source könnte DRM gebrauchen. Es gibt glaube ich auch einen entsprechenden Vorschlag von Sun, so ein offenes DRM-Modell zu machen. Habt ihr euch damit schon in irgendeiner Form auseinandergesetzt?
Also zum einen DRM prinzipiell kann gar nicht funktionieren. Wirtschaftlich wird das definitiv eine totale Katastrophe. Es wird ja immer verkauft zu diesem Argument, ja dann könnten auch irgendwie plötzlich alle Künstler werden glücklich und satt. Und das verschweigt die gesamten Probleme von vornherein. Denn die Infrastruktur, die für DRM notwendig ist, ist extrem aufwendig, sehr sehr teuer. Und damit haben wir finanziell eine ähnliche Situation wie bei physikalischer Distribution von CDs und anderen Geschichten, die für die Künstler ja auch nicht so wahnsinnig toll funktioniert haben. Wir haben aber gleichzeitig wieder eine entsprechende Zentralisierung der Kanäle in den Händen derjenigen, die DRM implementieren und durchführen, beziehungsweise die Kontrolle über diese Kanäle ausüben, was der eigentliche Grund für DRM ist. Denn die Medienindustrie möchte gerne diese Gatekeeper-Funktion, also diese Schlüsselfunktion, die sie ja haben, weiterhin behalten, indem sie dann über die Kanäle verfügen, um damit entsprechend die Künstler zu Knebelverträgen zwingen zu können, nach dem Motto, wenn du sie nicht unterzeichnest, da hinten sind noch 100 andere. Das ist ja der Hintergrund von DRM, der eigentliche. Und finanziell kann es nicht funktionieren. Das wird einem auch schon spätestens dann klar, wenn man sich überlegt, dass DRM-Infrastrukturen immer unterhalten werden müssen. Auch nach dem Verkauf, was auch immer ich anbiete, muss die DRM-Infrastruktur immer noch funktionieren. Das heißt, anders als bei einer CD, wo alle Kosten vor dem Verkauf liegen, muss sich bei DRM dann noch 30, 40 Jahre weiter die DRM-Infrastrukturen unterhalten. Das kann wirtschaftlich nicht funktionieren.
Ja, oder noch länger. Wer heute bei iTunes einen Song kauft, macht sich wahrscheinlich überhaupt nicht klar. Das sollte Apple morgen out of business sein. Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht besonders wahrscheinlich, aber ausgeschlossen ist es natürlich auch nicht. Dass dann vollkommen offen ist, wer die Registrierung des Computers, die erforderlich ist, um diese Inhalte abzuspielen, werden das dann auch durchführen, abgesehen von technischen Schwierigkeiten, die sich ergeben können, wenn so ein System halt einfach auch mal nicht funktioniert.
Deswegen, und das ist halt das eine und das andere ist sowieso, DRM basiert ja auf der Entmündigung des Nutzers. Es geht ja darum, dass man selber nicht mehr bestimmen kann, was man mit den Sachen auf dem eigenen Computer machen kann oder will. Es geht darum, den Benutzer letzten Endes vom Sicherheitsstandpunkt her als Fein zu betrachten, der ausgesperrt werden muss von seinem eigenen Computer. Der muss die Kontrolle verlieren über das, was der eigene Computer macht, damit DRM funktioniert. Und das ist mit freier Software einfach fundamental inkompatibel. Denn freie Software ist nur dann freie Software, wenn sie mir die Freiheit gibt, zu tun, was ich will. Und DRM basiert auf dem Prinzip, dass mein Computer mir diese Freiheit nehmen muss. Daher ist also dieses ganze Gerede um freie Software DRM in vieler Hinsicht einfach nur großer Unsinn. Da werden Versprechungen gemacht, weil DRM ist auch ein Versprechen von einem sehr, sehr großen Geschäft letztlich. Die Medienindustrie ist in heller Panik, ist bereit, jedem, der ihnen irgendwie die Wunderdroge verspricht, da großes Geld zu geben. Aber das ist so ein bisschen so dieses Snake Oil Prinzip, wo man halt sagt, das ist deine Wunderdroge, die heilt dich von AIDS-Impotenz und was weiß ich noch, was alles auf einmal.
Macht deinen Abwasch.
Genau, und die wäscht auch dein Auto oder was auch immer. Das ist so eine Heilsversprechung, die DRM ganz offensichtlich nicht einhalten kann. Das ist prinzipiell unmöglich. Und je länger die Leute glauben, dass das funktionieren würde, umso schlimmer, weil gleichzeitig drum herum jede Menge Gesetze aufgebaut werden, die die Gesellschaft mehr und mehr einschränken und reglementieren und selbst einfache Dinge wie eine DVD abzuspielen, mittlerweile zum strafbaren Akt machen. Das ist also gesellschaftlich wahnsinnig. Und ich glaub, ich hab das auch gelesen über Lawrence Lessigs Aussage, aber ich hab auch von ihm die Kommentare gelesen, dass da wohl, sagen wir mal, die Medienabteilung von Zahn ein bisschen übereifrig war und versucht hat seinen Namen wohl fürs eigene Produkt zu benutzen, mehr oder weniger, dass er das so auch nie gesagt hätte und auch ganz bestimmt nicht so meint, weil Lawrence Lessig selber auch kein großer Verfechter von DRM ist. Ich kenne ihn selber auch ganz gut insofern. Würde mich das sehr überraschen.
Ja, es gab ja auch eine ganze Menge Widersprüche, also Corey Doctorow und diverse andere sind da in dieser immer noch wütenden Diskussion auch entsprechend engagiert und sprechen sich dagegen aus. Trotzdem haben wir die Diskussion natürlich an der Backe. Jetzt ist es so, dass ein Projekt der FSF ist die neue Version der GPL, der New Public License, die Version V3. Ich hab mich hier schon vor ein paar Wochen schon mal mit Harald Welter ein bisschen über den aktuellen Stand der Dinge unterhalten. Da ist ja, spielt der DHM auch eine große Rolle. Kannst du das vielleicht nochmal kurz erläutern, was da jetzt der Ansatz ist für GPL V3 jenseits der Problematik, dass man jetzt nach zwölf Jahren grundsätzlich überhaupt erst mal den Rechtsänderungen und den geänderten Bedingungen sich anpassen muss? Wie weit der DHM da eine Rolle spielt?
Naja, das Problem ist, der DHM spielt zwangsweise eine Rolle. Aus dem ganz einfachen Grund, dass es eben nicht nur Software, die mit DHM belegt werden kann. Es geht auch um nicht nur Musik und andere Geschichten, sondern eben auch Software. Es gibt auch durchaus Gedankenmodelle und auch praktische Implementationen schon davon, dass man DHM benutzt, um die Software auf einem Rechner zu regulieren. Das ist so dieses TiWO-Ding, wo die Software nur dann läuft, wenn sie mit einem bestimmten Schlüssel signiert ist und die Hardware sich sonst weigert, das auszuführen. Das bedeutet ganz einfach, dass ich zwar theoretisch die Freiheiten der GPL habe in dem Moment, mir gibt das jemand, da kann mir auch den Source-Code geben, aber das nützt mir überhaupt nichts mehr, weil ich die Freiheit nicht wahrnehmen kann. Ich kann nicht mehr die Änderungen vornehmen. Es könnte sogar Leute geben, die auf die irrige Idee kommen, dass man mit DRM irgendwie den Source-Code kontrollieren könnte, sodass also auch alleine schon das Lesen oder Verändern oder wie auch immer das Source-Code technisch reguliert wird. Die sagen zwar ja, du hast doch das Recht, aber wenn man es wahrnehmen will, dann ist man eben technisch dazu nicht mehr in der Lage. Das ist zwar durchaus auch angreifbar vor Gericht, aber es erfordert eine sehr lange Diskussion. Und deswegen hat die GPL V3 von vornherein gesagt, erstens, was auch immer jetzt unter der GPL V3 steht, darf nicht mit DRM vor dem Zugriff verhindert werden. Also es darf nicht technisch verhindert werden, dass ich meine Freiheiten in freier Software, die mir durch die GPL gegeben werden, wahrnehmen kann. Es darf vor allem auch niemals behauptet werden, dass wenn ich mit der GPL zum Beispiel dann ein DRM-System baue und jemand anders schreibt eine freie Software, um da auch darauf zuzugreifen auf die Daten, dass der dann irgendwie meine Lizenz verletzt hätte oder ähnliche Sachen. Deswegen sagt die GPL V3 auch sehr klar von vornherein. Ich bin niemals eine wirksame technische Schutzmaßnahme im Sinne von EOCD und Co., weil es letzten Endes darum geht, die Freiheit zu bewahren. European Copyright Directive, das ist eine von denen. Das ist im Prinzip das europäische Äquivalent des Digital Millennium Copyright Act, der ja ein bisschen bekannter ist. Das ist so die Basis für die Umsetzung des zweiten Korpses im Urheberrecht, auch in Deutschland und Co. Da kommt das eigentlich her. Das Ganze hat ja eine lange Linie, wo das auch sich historisch verankert. Das kommt ja dann ursprünglich vom UNO-Level. Da hängt die WIPO, die World Intellectual Property Organization, sehr massiv mit drin, die World Trade Organization, die WTO. Die haben ja mehrere Verträge. Die WIPO hat den größten Teil, aber die WTO hat das TRIPS-Abkommen, Spezifisches Trade-Related Aspects of Intellectual Property Rights, das sich sehr massiv zur Verschärfung dieser gesamten Gesetzesphäre weltweit verständigt hat. EOCD und DMCA kommen letztlich genau von daher und werden jetzt auf nationaler Ebene umgesetzt. Die großen globalen Gesetzesvorhaben, die sind vor 20 Jahren durchgerauscht. Damals waren wir selber auch, ehrlich gesagt, das geben wir auch offen zu, da noch gar nicht so vertreten, dass wir dafür hätten machen können. Das hat uns ein bisschen unvorherbereitet getroffen. Das ist auch der Grund, warum wir jetzt so viel Arbeit auch auf dem UNO-Level machen. Weil wir, wenn es noch mal so kommt, und im Moment gibt es mehrere Vorhaben, angefangen vom Broadcasting-Treaty und andere Geschichten bei der WIPO, werden diese Bestrebungen wiederkommen, dass wir jetzt auch schon da Widerstand leisten können. Denn wenn man das erst versucht, wenn es ins nationale Recht umgesetzt wird, dann werden einem alle Politiker sagen, ja gut, aber wir haben internationale Verträge unterzeichnet, das müssen wir umsetzen, wir haben gar keine Wahl, unser Handlungsspielraum ist extrem begrenzt und letztlich steht man dann vor einer Wand, die man nicht durchbrechen kann.
Womit wir im Prinzip auch schon beim nächsten Punkt und vielleicht auch letzten Punkt angekommen sind, noch mal zurück zur Free Software Foundation. Was sind jetzt die konkreten politischen Aktivitäten, die ihr derzeit verfolgt und was mich auch noch mal interessieren würde, was ist FSF Europe offiziell? Ist das ein Verein, ein Verband? Kannst du da noch mal was zu sagen? Wie sieht der Arbeitsprozess auf in der FSF? Wie kann man da mitmachen?
Ich fange mal von vorne an. Also die Free Software Foundations, wie sie heute strukturiert sind, sind ein Netzwerk von globalen unabhängigen Schwesterorganisationen. Die sind voneinander unabhängig politisch, juristisch, personell. Sie existieren in den USA, die originale FSF. Es gibt die FSF Europe, die als erste FSF außerhalb der Vereinigten Staaten gegründet wurde. Es gibt eine FSF in Indien und jetzt seit kurzem auch eine FSF Lateinamerika. Dieses Netzwerk arbeitet sehr stark gemeinsam. Nicht alle Organisationen sind identisch. Auch die internen Organisationsformen sind unterschiedlich, weil die FSFs eben auch als Teil dieses Netzwerks die kulturellen Eigenheiten der verschiedenen Gebiete entsprechend abbilden. Und so hat halt jedes Gebiet, das von einer FSF in irgendeiner Art und Weise bearbeitet wird oder vertreten wird, seinen eigenen Ansatz.
Es ist ja auch klar, gerade in den USA hängt es immer sehr von der Organisationsform an, wie man überhaupt politisch aktiv werden darf, wie man den Kongressabgeordneten gegenüber steht etc. Das ist ja in der EU nicht anders.
Und die FSF Europa selber ist ein nach deutschem Recht eingetragener Gemeinnütziger Verein ausgestaltet, entsprechend dem deutschen Recht. Unsere Satzung ist auch online, insofern kann man die auch durchwiesen.
Also die FSF Europe ist in Deutschland. Kann man erstmal festhalten, wo ist die Zentrale, gibt es sowas?
Da eingetragen, wobei das eigentlich in vieler Hinsicht irrelevant ist, weil die Mitglieder sind, kommen halt aus ganz Europa. Irgendwo musste es sein. Es gibt auch kein europäisches Recht für eine Organisation. Insofern mussten wir irgendein Land wählen. Deutschland kannten wir recht gut, deswegen haben wir das genommen. Eine Zentrale in dem Sinne gibt es nicht. Wir haben ein Verteilbüro in Düsseldorf, wo auch entsprechend viele von ihnen Bürofunktionalitäten zu Hause sind. Wir hatten ein Büro in Hamburg, das habe ich mittlerweile aufgelöst, weil ich nach Zürich umgezogen bin. Da werden wir jetzt wieder was aufbauen, zusammen mit meinen Praktikanten, und dann werden wir noch ein oder zwei Leute dort auch suchen. In Mailand haben wir noch ein Büro, wo jemand Vollzeit arbeitet. Wir haben eine Person Vollzeit in Brüssel, demnächst auch noch eine in Göteborg, und wir haben einen Vollzeitmedienkoordinator im Raum Frankfurt.
Wie finanziert sich das?
Sehr stark über Spenden letztlich. Unsere Arbeit ist im größten Teil Spenden finanziert, wobei es einmal die Möglichkeit gibt, normal nach deutschem Recht zu spenden. Das andere, was wir haben, ist das Fellowship. Das ist eine Mitmachkampagne letzten Endes, bei der die Fellows selber für sich einen selbst gewählten Beitrag wählen. Also empfohlen sind 120 Euro, Minimum sind 60 Euro. Sie kriegen dann als Dankeschön und auch als Werkzeug für die praktische Arbeit quasi eine Krypto-Karte, mit der sie ihre E-Mail verschlüsseln können, mit der sie ihre Daten sichern können, die auch SSH, also sichere Logins, authentifizieren kann und andere Dinge. Als Nifty-Gadget auch, mit dem man auch viel Spaß haben kann.
Um den Litnes-Faktor zu erhöhen auf Partys. Also 120 Euro pro Jahr.
60 Euro, 120 Euro pro Jahr, freiwillig gewählt entsprechend. Und das macht uns, weil es halt auch eine stabile Einnahmequelle ist, die Arbeit möglich. Ciarán O'Riordan, der arbeitet für uns Vollzeit in Brüssel, hat unter anderem an den Software-Patenten sehr viel gemacht. Es sind ihre, der die Irish Free Software Organization ursprünglich aufgebaut hat. Den konnten wir einstellen, auf Basis des Fellowships beispielsweise. Und dazu gibt es dann noch ein Portal. Also unsere Fellows haben auch eine add.fsfe.org-Email-Adresse, um halt auch die Unterstützung sichtbar zu machen. Es gibt ein Portal mit Blogs und anderen Geschichten, wo man dann auch einen Blog-Aggregator hat. Ich hab mein eigenes Blog auch auf der Fellowship-Seite. Und die Blogs laufen dann alle zusammen in eine Diskussion eben über diese Themen, über die Frage der Freiheit im digitalen Zeitalter. Die Idee dahinter ist dann auch, dass man das Ganze weiterbringt, auch in andere Kreise, weil wir häufig ja immer zu denselben Leuten reden leider. Es ist sehr schwierig, Menschen zu erreichen in anderen Gebieten, die dieses Thema noch nicht für sich entdeckt haben. Und der Versuch ist eben auch, eine Bildsprache zu finden, eine gemeinsame Kommunikation zu finden, Wege zu finden, diese Leute einzubinden. Und da soll das Fellowship eben auch einen wichtigen Teil spielen. Deswegen haben wir das auch mittlerweile, dass viele Fellows regelmäßig Vorträge geben. Die kriegen von uns Infomaterial, die machen auch Infomaterial, dass wir dann auch wieder andere Fellows verteilen können und so weiter und so fort. Einfach um das Ganze zu multiplizieren. Wir müssen mehr Leute darüber informieren. Es ist wichtig, dass wir nicht in der Subkultur bleiben, weil letztlich geht es alle an. Und wir brauchen die politische Stärke, die auch dann in der Masse liegt, um entsprechend unsere Vorstellungen durchzusetzen, weil sonst übernehmen halt Madonna und Britney Spears die Welt.
Ihr seid ja hier auch auf dem Linungstag mit einem relativ großen Stand präsent. Gibt es noch weitere Veranstaltungen, wo du jetzt schon sagen kannst, dass ihr da auftauchen werdet in der nächsten Zeit?
Gute Frage. Also es wird in absehbarer Zeit die dritte internationale Konferenz zur GPLv3 geben, nach aller Voraussicht nach in nicht allzu ferner Zukunft in Spanien. Dann gibt es häufiger Events. Also wir hatten jetzt gerade sehr viele, wegen der WM wurden sehr viele Events ja nach vorne verlegt.
Wie auch der Linungstag.
Eben. Deswegen drängelt sich das im Moment alles sehr stark. Also ich selber war vor zwei Wochen in Brasilien beim Free Software Forum, letzte Woche vor Gericht in Luxemburg mit dem EU-Antitrust-Fall mit Microsoft und jetzt bin ich hier. Insofern, das ist also schon im Moment etwas gedrängt und gedrückt. Das wird dann sich etwas entspannen, während der WM ist relativ wenig. Aber ansonsten, wir haben auch bei uns auf der Webseite entsprechend immer so upcoming Events. Da kann man dann schauen, wo wir sind, wen man von uns da treffen kann, was es da zu sehen gibt und so weiter und so fort. Insofern versuchen wir, da die Infos auch rauszukriegen.
Okay, würde ich sagen, haben wir es ganz gut gemacht. Die ganzen Links, die wir jetzt hier angedeutet haben, finden sich wie immer in den Show Notes, in den Beschreibungen zu der Chaosradio Express Ausgabe. Findet ihr auf ChaosradioCCCDE. Wenn euer Player das unterstützt, könnt ihr auch schön in die MP3-Datei reinschauen. Dann steht es auch einfach direkt im File. Ich bedanke mich bei dir, Georg. Vielleicht noch eine Webseite sollten wir vielleicht sagen. FSF-Europe ist unter fsfeurope.org genau zu erreichen. Dort findet ihr also schon mal den Kern der Informationen. Ich bedanke mich für das Interview. Mein Name ist wie immer Tim Pritlove, Georg Greve war zu Gast. Ich sage tschüss, bis zum nächsten Mal über Chaosradio Express.